I was curious that head coaches are
managers in the four major US sports who
is the is there a coach who whoa do
breeze just walked in what a great
surprise
can you sit down for a moment I got I
got the Trager folks over there
yeah the Timberline 1300 at home yeah I
got Chad over there You've ribs over
there yeah I got brisket oh my goodness
I'm gonna have to hit that on the way
out
how you doing we're good I'm great how
you doing I'm good I don't have too many
questions though going on with my career
so like I'm just gonna relax and hang
with the family and you know let the
process kind of play itself out but if
you if you want to play you can play
next year yes absolutely okay yes what
about broadcasting I don't know what do
you think I'll ask your advice well I
was wondering about this what if there
wasn't opening let's say Tony Romo went
to Monday Night Football or he doesn't
go or maybe there is Monday Night
Football that would be open are you
interested in something like that
I I'd say I'd say at some point yes
absolutely but that would not be a
factor in coming back to play or not if
I if I if I can if I could if I I know I
can play but if the if the desire is
there then I would play first and
foremost but you've always had that
passion you loved working out you loved
getting better and did was there a
moment that you started to doubt
yourself there's no no no I wouldn't
call it I wouldn't call it doubt at all
I mean I think I think everybody's
making a big deal out of this maybe
bigger than it should be I mean at least
from my perspective I I look at it as
listen I just I just finished year 19 at
some point this is coming right
there was a time when I thought I could
play forever you know I mean I think for
the first 15 years of my career I felt
like it would just last forever but I'd
say over the last three years truly I've
approached each year just one at a time
saying that I'm truly gonna play this
year like it's my last and therefore I'm
gonna enjoy it that way too
I'm enjoy the locker room a little bit
more I'm gonna enjoy the plane flights
home after a big Road win more dance it
up a little bit because our locker room
turns into a club up in the game right
you know with the lights and the smoke
and everything I mean but just truly
enjoy and join my teammates and you know
what I've had more fun playing football
with that mindset the last three years
than I ever have and we've had a ton of
success doing it too so I don't want to
take that for granted but I also
understand that listen there's there's a
lot of things I want to do life after
football and I think my next chapter is
gonna be better than in this first
chapter and my kids now are aged 11 9 7
and 5 they're playing all kinds of
sports you know I want to be a part of
that I want to coach them I want to I
want to be there for every second but I
don't want to miss it so listen there's
there's a sacrifice right that goes with
playing this game yeah and a commitment
so there's just that this is all part of
the process you know of evaluating it
each year and I think it's healthy to
step away when the season ends and
decompress and just go through that
process so that's the that's where I'm
at right now
and it feels like you know with the Kobe
Bryant death and his age and he had
started his second career and you know
he was great at what he was doing and
had that you're about the same age you
and yeah yeah he was 41 41 yeah yeah and
then I don't know how that hits you at
you know it hit me you know I'm a lot
older but it's just the children part of
it you know that your daughter and yeah
listen his daughter being with him I
mean for a parent you just you you ache
and you hurt so badly for his wife and
and his and his kids and I I think I
think what also hit me too with with his
passing was here was a guy who truly
transcended basketball you know so many
so many guys in our league if you think
about it are between the age of 22 and
25
years old right these guys grew up
idolizing Kobe Bryant right these guys
are now professional football players
but you can honestly say that Kobe
probably had a tremendous influence on
them right and so regardless of what
sports you play like you recognize his
greatness not just as a player but as a
leader and just how driven he was and
then s/he Trant was transitioning into
kind of this second career as you know
coaching his daughter you know watching
her develop the same love and passion
for the game that has had done so much
for him and obviously what he was doing
with his career and everything he was
involved with I mean there was so much
to be admired and so I think Kobe lives
within so many of us because not only
were we fans but we were inspired by a
lot of the things that he did and I
think that's the great thing about
sports and having that second career you
know that he did where he wanted to be
as successful as he was as a basketball
player and and we're short on time and I
and I do appreciate you and I just
wanted to come say hello it was awesome
no in smoothie King is who you're
representing down here and I appreciate
those guys bringing you by and it's
always great to see you you know I hate
to see guys leave before it's like
sometimes we push people out I try to
hold them back you know to make sure
that they stay as long as as they can
and hopefully you'll get that clarity
that'll allow you to make that decision
because it is a big decision that you'll
make go get some ribs it's great to see
you as always thanks for your friendship
the entire season and making yourself
available we appreciate that mr. Dan
thank you buddy
Thank You drew brees everybody
that was a nice surprise you know week
he had some commitments and then we were
like alright well you know we have drew
usually on every Super Bowl but I just
glad he stopped by yeah McClellan did he
just show up for the food is that
exactly I'm just happening like I'm fine
but that's a veteran maneuver right
there yeah giving Todd Fritz a big bonus
coverage on that when Todd did not let
up on drew Brees popping back that was
awesome I had no idea he was gonna be
able to show up he was a book through
and out of things going on and his agent
Chris Stewart and they brought him over
here was a very very cool I thought
somebody came out of the audience to go
shake everybody's hand and I go wait a
minute which shows not over none of us
had any idea about what a great surprise
to rapidly now it's just there's so many
times like we keep waiting for athletes
to retire you ask them are you gonna
retire and there's so many good good
people in this business and and Drew is
certainly one of those guys can't help
but admire him and you know if he
decides to walk away he gets to walk
away after 19 years yeah Paulie
he's elbow deep in barbecue right now
that's what it's focused on seized F
initely gonna retire yep that's that's
we can go by what he's eating there for
more Dan Patrick show tune in to
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]